un chef comme ça ça te prend ça peut
être 1000 $ et plus par week end ne
cherchez plus sur les plates formes de
location pour la semaine de relâche les
carnets de réservation sont pleins il
serait pas mettre autant de réserver la
semaine de relâche mi-mai et y encore
des possibilités à l'heure actuelle on
est à 78 % du taux d'occupation
le 22 % qui restent à combler en fait
c'est des challenges importants qui
parle
la ruée vers les chalets ont entamé cet
été se poursuit et ce partout au québec
province et une trop grosse demande et
on manque d'un menteur sur le marché
actuellement
des régions comme les cris les
laurentides et charlevoix sont très
recherchés principalement pour leurs
emplacements près des stations de ski
cette année ce qui ne va pas vraiment
ensemble mesure sanitaire oblige il faut
réserver avant de se présenter il ya
certaines stations qui ont moins
d'achalandage qui sont des stations un
petit peu moins populaires qui ont des
billets journaliers mais vraiment la
consigne si on veut pas malgré les
recommandations de bien planifier
plusieurs parents hésitent à ma
perception qu'on va vouloir aller déjà
réservé mais on n'a pas un plan précis
là parce que dans le fond n'a pas bien
compris ce qui sera ouvert au québec à
jeter du lest pour aider les familles
musée cinéma patinoire et piscine
intérieure seront ouverts c'est une
belle occasion de se dire qu'est ce que
les gens viennent visiter dans ma région
quand tu nous choisissent comme des
stations touristiques mais les parents
devront être créatif lieu des grands
classiques qui vont se remplir plus vite
et à ce moment là c'est peut-être
l'occasion des cours et découvrir pour
atténuer l'effet de la pandémie sur le
moral des enfants mais aussi des parents
ici marie josée paquet comme radio
canada montréal